there are two blessings that people
greatly take for granted it's free time
and health the other one that you guys
have heard it's an authentic hadith
talking about taking advantage of five
before five and one of those things is
health it be no claim a great physician
and scholar he emphasizes this point he
talks about health is one of the most
precious favors from the almighty from
the Creator one of the most precious
favors that the Creator has bestowed
upon his servants the most generous of
gifts the most plentiful of his bounties
rather than even more health is the most
precious of favors without exception so
it's fitting that whoever is granted a
portion of it of this fortune that he
cherishes it he cherishes at health that
blessing he preserves it health and he
guards it against harm and chronic
disease brothers and sisters this is one
of the greatest issues affecting our
health let me share with you some
staggering statistics that really pushed
this point home do you know that we are
the first generation kids in this
generation are the first of its kind not
expected to outlive their parents did
you understand that let that sink in did
you know that the government is
expecting by 2040 that it's federal
budget 100 percent of it will be going
towards Medicare and Medicaid 100
percent by 24 that's how rapidly chronic
disease is spreading it's a health
crisis an epidemic the department get
the Department of Defense has named
chronic disease as an existential threat
to this country let that sink in did you
know that over a hundred million not a
hundred thousand you know your zeros
hundred million people living in America
us Americans here I'm born here mostly
you born here Americans we love our
country right of course people have
diabetes or pre-diabetic but death sink
in and most people they don't know that
they have or that they're expected to
have full-blown diabetes too and it
usually takes to progress about five
years am I correct we got two doctors in
the houses right yeah thirty percent of
kids have chronic diseases thirty
percent one in two Americans has a
chronic disease that's 50% of America
one in to see the me or you let it not
be either of us or any of us God woman
one in three have multiple chronic
diseases you guys understand my english
hablas espanol 40% 40% of Americans are
obese add that with the 30% that are
overweight that's 70% obese or
overweight I'm almost done and then
we'll bring on our special guests one in
two of Americans are expected to have
cancer one and two very scary very sad
and this all comes from chronic diseases
that are reversible that by lifestyle
choices by food choices as our guests
now are going to come on and talk about
we can go ahead and be God willing not
included in this statistic and we can
start to help honor this vehicle that
the crater has given us to get us
through life by cherishing it by
preserving it and guarding it against
many of these chronic diseases that are
affecting the majority of us living
today so let me bring on our next
speaker Jim Marlow he's not only a
nutritionist he's a health researcher
educator consultant he has been
enthusiastically studying nutrition and
what he calls the other fundamentals of
health for 40 years he has been teaching
people how to eat healthier and how to
live healthier on a professional level
for 32 years from 2000 to 2007 he was
the chief nutritionist at dr. Joseph
Mercola
optimal and Wellness Center when at its
popularity of the dr. Mercola website
the optimal Wellness Center was the
busiest this was the busiest nutrition
based health center in the United States
since 2007 Jim Marlow has worked in
close association with nutritionally
knowledgeable holistic dentist dr. Lena
Garcia and the family practice holistic
physician dr. Joseph Grasso ladies and
gentlemen we have in the house
Jim Marlow Thank You Eddie for inviting
me to speak here today and thank you all
for coming
my intention is to impart some knowledge
and understanding and if I'm blessed
even some wisdom that will help to
empower you to know how to better take
care of yourselves and realize what the
title of my talk is which is nutrition
for better energy and brain power now
when you're improving your new tree
you're not just going to be improving
your energy in your brainpower every
aspect of your biology benefits from
improved nutrition but I thought it
would give some special focus to better
energy and brain power for two very
basic and important reasons in all the
years that I've been doing nutrition and
health counseling on a professional
level the two most common complaints I
hear from people I work with are I don't
have any energy I'm tired all the time
what can I do for more energy and the
other most common complaint is what can
I do to get rid of brain fog I can't
remember as well as I used to and this
is people in their 20s their 30s or 40s
you're not just not just older people
like myself I turned 60 earlier this
year but I feel my brainpower is as good
as it's ever been and actually getting
stronger in many ways but most of the
people I work with I say at least four
out of five people I work with admit to
me that they have some degree of what
they what I call brain fog their ability
to think learn and remember is not as
good as they know it can be their
ability to focus their mental clarity is
this not very good and it's it's very
enjoyable for me to experience that
usually the very first benefit that
people experience from improving their
nutrition is the brain fog begins to
lift and I understand why that's the
very first benefit because I've been
I've been teaching for years something I
learned from actually a couple of my
mentors many many years ago that whether
you're aware of it or not the brain is
the most nutrient sensitive organ of the
body that is the brain is is the organ
that's most sensitive to the quality and
quantity
of protein and fat and carbohydrates and
vitamins and minerals and other
nutrients that you're putting into your
body and I once made that statement to a
brain surgeon that the brain is the most
nutrient sensitive organ of the body and
he said now I don't think so and I asked
him I asked him a follow-up question and
I knew he would know the answer to this
I asked them what organ of the body is
most sensitive to oxygen and he said hmm
you may have a point because there's no
doubt our brain cells are the cells that
have the most urgent need for oxygen on
an ongoing basis
oxygen of course is our most important
nutrient and it's the catalyst for
energy production and every cell in the
body needs to produce sufficient amounts
of energy in order to function properly
if a cell brain cells muscle cells
immune cells if any cell in the body is
not producing sufficient amounts of
energy it's not going to function very
well if a cell is not producing any
energy it's dead so energy is really
it's the key to cellular life it's it's
it's it's the factor that affects the
quality of our life of our health most
of all is how well is your body
producing energy and the energy issue is
not just a quantity issue it's important
to have enough energy of course that's
fundamentally important but it's that's
not enough to really be healthy in a
sustained way it's actually equally
important that your cells produce energy
efficiently it's the quality of the
energy matters as much as the quantity
of the energy because if your cells are
producing energy inefficiently like from
eating's consuming stimulants like
refined and processed sugar which is the
most commonly consumed addictive
stimulant or from consuming caffeine
which the second most commonly consumed
addictive stimulant yes those consuming
those foods they will they will
stimulate increased energy production
but it's not good quality energy
the more you stimulate energy production
the less and less efficiently that
energy will be produced and the more
metabolic waste you have as a natural
byproduct of producing energy
inefficiently a valid analogy would be
the difference between a car that is
very fuel efficient and gets like 40
miles to a gallon in a car that's very
fuel inefficient you know gas guzzling
car that only gets 5 miles to a gallon
what vehicle produced produces the most
environmental pollution of course the
gas guzzling car has got more exhaust
more waste coming out of its tailpipe
it's the same thing in biological
systems in the human body when your body
is producing energy efficiently you're
generating a lot less metabolic waste
that ultimately your body has to get rid
of and it's Energy expensive for the
body to get rid of it it's energy
expensive to detoxify and the more
energy your body's putting into
detoxification the less energy it has
for cellular repair and regeneration and
in healing and and rebalancing when you
get knocked off balance and we all get
knocked off balance because we all have
stress in our lives and stress in all
the different forms that comes in that's
what knocks us off balance you know
physically mentally emotionally but when
your body is producing energy
efficiently you're producing less of
your own metabolic waste and your liver
and your kidneys especially appreciate
that because the liver and the kidneys
and the major organs of the body they
have to ultimately take the metabolic
waste out of the bloodstream and then we
need to excrete it so the energy issue
is of course fundamental to our biology
and I really want to emphasize it's once
again it's not enough to have enough
energy it's equally important that that
energy be produced efficiently for
overall and long-term health and for the
prevention of degenerative diseases so
that's just a little introduction and
now I want to get into what I really
intended as far as the main part of my
presentation so Eddie I help the clock
right in front of me it's 154 how much
time do I have 30 minutes
okay so what's that okay so I have an
intention to cover quite a bit of ground
so I'm gonna go fairly fast Eddie told
me that he's you're gonna be posting
this as a Dean Show episode right so you
can review this if you're if you're not
taking any notes and you find something
that I said to be especially valuable or
or interesting you can review it by
pulling it up as a Dean show episode but
what's okay so Eddie wants wants me to
tell my story so I'll just tell it
briefly so the reason I started studying
nutrition at the age of 20 which is 40
years ago 1977 was because I reached the
time in my life where I was sick and
tired of being sick and tired all the
time I was chronically ill for the first
20 years of my life I had all kind of
messy problems that I won't get into but
at the age of 20 I was also sick of
going to doctors and at the age of 20 I
recognized that what the doctors were
were giving me doing for me prescription
drugs was not only not helping me I was
actually getting worse in the long run
and I wanted to know how to get better
and unfortunately there weren't any real
doctors that I knew at that time not
like dr. Joe Grasso who's a real doctor
but I was seeing doctors that were
little more than legalized drug pushers
all they ever did was you know here's
you know here's here's a drug for this
symptom here's a drug for another
symptom I was I was I was sick and tired
of taking drugs I was sick and tired of
going to the doctor I wanted to know how
to be healthy and what I could do to be
healthy and
our family doctor had nothing to offer
me nothing to offer me and I came to
understand over time why he had nothing
to offer me because in medical school
you don't you know you don't learn about
health you study disease and you study
drugs that treat the diseases or
surgical procedures but health is not a
subject that doctors learn about in
medical school and it's very important
to understand that so be very careful
who you trust and what you buy into and
certainly medical doctors have their
place in urgent care emergency care
immediate care but I decided that in
order to be healthy I was going to need
to take responsibility for my own health
and the only way I knew how to begin to
do that was to educate myself and I
started studying nutrition and the main
reason I started studying nutrition is
as he said he wants me to wanted me to
say I was sick and tired of being sick
and tired all the time at the age of 20
and so my main motivation for improving
my nutrition was to have more physical
energy but actually before I experienced
that the very first benefit I realized
was a lifting of the brain fog that I
had and I didn't even realize at the age
of 20 that I actually had brain fog
until I started experiencing something
different in the way of mental clarity
until I was 20 years of age my favorite
foods were pizza ice cream fried chicken
candy fast food burgers with french
fries soft drinks this all this kind of
fake garbage food I was putting into my
body and my health was really a
reflection of it
my basic teaching about about food
nutrition is if you want to be real
healthy then eat real food and real food
is simple food that does not come with a
label with a list of ingredients no
Eddie you brought all fake food you know
it's okay so that's that's fine too you
do
show and tell with what fake food is but
where is the real food well I have some
real food that I brought with me I'll be
showing you at the end of my
presentation here but well I I hope I
hope there's nobody here who has any of
these fake food items in your home
because you're you're not going to
nourish yourself with any of this stuff
this is you're gonna burden your biology
with any of this stuff ya know you you
you may have you may have a a momentary
pleasant experience in your mouth you
know your taste buds might like some of
this this fake food but none of this
stuff is going to be pleasant for your
your liver your kidneys your heart your
lungs your brain your nervous system
your immune system no the rest of you is
going to suffer you know it's a huge
mistake to eat as if your taste buds are
the most important part of your body and
the corporate dominated commercial food
industry is kind of programmed all of us
to be more attentive to tastes in price
and convenience and for many American
consumers the the most important the
most important aspect of the food by far
which is the nutritional value is an
afterthought if it's a thought at all
for many people so well then you need a
need they need to to to be educated they
need to watch Jim Marlowe's appearances
on the Dean show and Eddy himself I told
Eddie the other day he's bidding he's
becoming quite the nutritional
evangelist I mean he's making some very
very powerful Dean show videos having to
do with helping to wake up people to
freeing themselves of the the bad habits
of consuming fake foods of various kinds
you know and I I think that's the proper
way to think of it is you're not if
if you're currently eating any any fake
food like this when you when you
subtract this from your life you're not
giving anything up you're freeing
yourself of bad habits and you're
allowing your your your biology to
realize a higher level of health and
you're creating the possibility of
realizing a higher level of health
possibly even realizing your full health
potential at any time in your life you
know most people in this culture learn
to accept the very low level of health
as long as they feel OK as long as
they're not acutely ill as long as
they're not in acute pain or discomfort
they're satisfied ok you know the
direction of our life force energy is
toward healing and health our body has a
god-given intelligence and capability to
know how to be healthy our body wants to
be healthy it's always trying to be
healthy if you cut yourself at heels you
don't even have to think about it the
body has a god-given innate intelligence
and capability to be healthy but this
health that I'm talking about is not
realizing magically we need to get our
nutrition and the rest of our self-care
right enough in order to realize the
health potential that is within us so
very important to develop what I call
nutritional integrity nutritional
integrity is all about setting standards
for what is acceptable food and drink
for your body and then being faithful to
those standards not strict with yourself
but being faithful as I was saying to
dr. Joseph fish and and Eddie knows this
from my teachings that I don't want
anybody to follow any of my nutrition
recommendations strictly strictly is a
hard word it's it's got a it's got like
a negative energy to it when we're doing
something strictly it's because we don't
really want to do it but we
we have to do it or someone is forcing
us to do it and we're forcing in
ourselves and when you're doing
something strictly it's only a matter of
time before you stress yourself and you
look for an out you look to stop doing
what you're doing strictly but when
you're doing something faithfully
there's a much better energy when you're
doing something faithfully it's because
you want to do it you believe in the
value of it there's positive energy to
doing something faithfully and your
attitude about what you're doing in
regard to your self-care and your
nutritional practices is very very
important and you know my intention has
been for many many years now to honor my
body with the best quality food that God
makes available to me in the environment
in which I live and the the rewards are
incredibly enjoyable to feel good all
the time is is the exact opposite of
what I experienced the first 20 years of
my life where I felt not good over time
so just to back up and and get more
specifically into nutrition for energy
and brainpower so nutrition for a better
energy and brainpower really begins with
having appreciation for the most basic
way in which we nourish ourselves that
is very very common for people to take
for granted but it's really the most
important aspect of raw biology and it
should never be taken for granted but it
often is and that's our breath our
breath our inhale is our most basic form
of nutrition we inhale air to get our
most important nutrient oxygen and you
can improve the quality of your breath
this is something worth putting time and
attention to on a daily basis to do some
type of
breathing practice conscious breathing
some type of breathing practice on a
daily basis for just a few minutes maybe
to begin with but to do some type of
conscious breathing practice on a daily
basis and if you faithfully do this over
time you'll notice that the quality of
your breath improves the the fullness of
your inhale improves the completeness of
your exhale improves and your overall
health will improve but oxygen is our
most important nutrient for catalyzing
energy production if you if you if
anybody doubts that oxygen is there is
your most important nutrient hold your
breath see how long you can do that so
doing daily breathing exercise is
something I committed to a long time ago
I don't miss a day of daily breathing
exercise and I do a variety of daily a
variety of different type of exercises
the the breathing exercise I'm actually
most enthusiastic to do for about the
last year and a half is I call I do what
I call deep breathing leg raises and my
deep breathing leg raises go like this
I'm laying on my back and I inhale as
joyfully and as fully as I can and then
as I exhale I lift up my legs in good
form as as straight as possible
when I started doing this exercise in
August of 2016
this particular breathing exercise I did
as many leg raises as I could at that
particular time and I was able to do
6767 what I call deep breathing leg
exercises and I have persisted with this
exercise since August of 2016 and little
by little I've added more repetitions
more deep breaths and repetitions and
this morning I did 319 deep breathing
leg raises
so I
worked my way up from 67 deep-breathing
leg raises in August of 2016 to this
morning December 23rd 2017 I did 319 and
my plan is to my intention is to go up
to at least 400 and possibly maybe even
500 but it's as I'm adding more
repetitions it's taken me more time it
took me 20 minutes to do my deep
breathing leg exercises but my advice to
you is find something that you're
enthusiastic to do and something that
that you feel good with and that you're
you you you know that this is good for
you something that you look forward to
doing related to improving the quality
of your breath deep breathing or or just
even just conscious breathing but
there's there's many different types of
breathing exercises you can do there's
no end to it really but find something
that that you like to do that you feel
good with when you do it and then do it
faithfully on a daily basis at least for
a few minutes you know if you have more
time than do it for longer but nutrition
for better energy and brainpower begins
with improving the quality of your
breath the next way to improve your
energy and brain power is with the next
most important nutrient for the physical
body which is water the quality and
quantity of water you consume every day
is a fundamental influence on your
health throughout our entire lives our
body is mostly water and of course the
quality and quantity of water that you
consume will affect your energy your
brain power or lack of it so it's very
important to keep yourself very well
hydrated another reason to avoid
dehydrating beverages like well I know
no one here consumes alcohol of course
but coffee is dehydrating to the body
and also teas most most teas black tea
and
see I know they're very heavily promoted
I never I never support that those are
those beverages are dehydrating to the
body and there's other problems with
them too but it's very important to keep
yourself well hydrated with good quality
water good quality water is got to be
it's got to be fluoride free water
fluoride is neurotoxic there's really
really strong science supporting that
fluoride hurts the brain especially of
children there's there's studies that
have come out in recent years that show
that there's a very strong correlation
between the level of fluoride and the
water that children are drinking and
that then the child's IQ the higher the
level of fluoride in the water the lower
the IQ so fluoride is neurotoxic and
fluoride also inhibits enzymes enzymes
are the catalysts in our biology for
energy production in most of our
biochemical reactions so this is really
important this is not just a nice thing
to do because I'm mentioning this this
is fundamentally important that you're
drinking water that is not contaminated
with fluoride yes the fluoride that's
that's in the water is added to the
water supposedly to reduce tooth decay
despite the propaganda about that there
is actually very little science
supporting that there's any value in
drinking fluoridated water for reducing
tooth decay but there's a lot of science
supporting that fluoride is neurotoxic
it hurts the thyroid gland if you're
hurting your thyroid gland the thyroid
gland is the master gland of your
metabolism the thyroid gland which is
right here produces hormones that
regulate the rate of your metabolism
your metabolism is all about how
efficiently your eat efficiently you're
producing energy so fluoride for flight
hurts the
it will hurt your energy it it's it's an
obstacle to good health so be very
attentive to the quality of water that
you're consuming and consume enough
water there's another thing I want to
mention here in regard to the water
issue because it's so common it's like
it's so common these days for people to
be walking around or to have plastic
bottles water okay
well that's better than being yourself
to be come dehydrated or under hydrated
but first time use plastic water bottles
have plastic molecules in them okay this
is especially important for men if if
you value your testosterone level and
your testosterone level definitely is
going to affect your energy and your
vitality plastic molecules are end
ricchan disruptors endocrine disruptors
are chemicals that mess with your
hormones and specifically plastic
molecules are known to be xenoestrogens
xenoestrogens are foreign synthetic
chemicals that actually act like
estrogen in your body and work against
the activity of testosterone so I don't
like I don't think it's just you know a
minor thing to to not drink water out of
plastic bottles I never drink water out
of plastic bottles I have my water in
glass glass bottled waters are available
it's not not so convenient yes glass
breaks and it's heavier but I will not
drink water out of plastic bottles and I
suggest that you make that part of your
your nutritional integrity because water
is nutrition for our body very important
nutrition the second most important
nutrient after after the air we breathe
and the oxygen that that the air
contains is our most important nutrient
of course then water so phase out
drinking water out of plastic bottles
and you'll have a you'll very likely
have a noticeably healthier testosterone
level better energy and better fight
tality okay so the next aspect of
nutrition I need to address for better
energy and brainpower is of course food
nutrition now getting your food
nutrition right does begin with having
appreciation for what I mentioned before
and I'll mention it again because it is
so fundamentally important if you want
to be real healthy then eat real food
and real food is simple food that does
not come with a label with a list of
ingredients okay real food is meats from
healthy animals real food is fish from
clean waters real food is eggs from
healthy chickens real food can be dairy
products from not just cows but goats
and sheep and potentially camels and and
and and other animals real food is
vegetables real food is fruits real food
is nuts and seeds and real food can be
legumes which are beans lentils and peas
and grain grain products so those are
the real food groups that are available
to us for the nourishing of our bodies
now not all of those real food groups
are going to have equal value for us but
it's really important to have
appreciation for what real food is if
you're buying stuff like this you're not
making healthy choices in fact you're
making the wrong choices in regard to
improving your energy and your
brainpower so in regard to real food
there are some fundamentally important
quality issues in regard to real food
that are often taken for granted by
other nutritionists and nutritionally
oriented doctors but I
never take I never take the basics for
granted because you know is any of you
know who if you have any any practice if
you have any art like you know Eddie and
Joe practice Brazilian jiu-jitsu isn't
isn't it
aren't the fundamentals of your practice
always what's most important
you know the fundamentals of
chiropractic care dr. Joseph itchin and
Joe you know the fundamentals of Massage
Therapy you know whatever you're doing
the fundamentals are or just never to be
taken for granted if you do that's a
mistake so the fundamentals of real food
other than having appreciation for what
real foods are and you know real foods
are wholesome foods that God provides
not adulterated are not manipulated by
man in any way these are all adulterated
manipulated foods this is this is none
of this occurs naturally this is all the
result of food processing technology and
the FDA the emphasis here is not
nutritional value the emphasis here is
convenience and taste and possibly price
fact certainly price its shelf life but
not nutritional value so you want to
become a nutrition first eater I don't
say to completely you know disregard
attention to convenience and taste and
certainly you know we all have our
budgets and we can only buy what we can
afford but really to get your nutrition
right you really need to become what I
call a nutrition first eater and when
you're planning or shopping or preparing
to have the intention to nourish
yourself rather than the intention to
indulge your taste buds or to eat what's
most convenient or to buy what's on sale
if those are your priorities if your
priorities are taste price convenience
shelf-life
you're only gonna ever nourish yourself
by accident and if you're only ever
nourishing yourself by accident your
health is going to be in a precarious
state it's only a matter of time before
you begin to suffer consequences from
not nourishing yourself on purpose
intentionally so in regard to real food
there's something that I am strongly
attentive to both in my personal
practice and in everybody that I work
with and that is this simple lesson the
fresher your food the better the
nutrient value of foods only goes
downhill over time the fresher the food
the better I personally never eat
anything out of my freezer I don't
support eating previously frozen food
for building health there's value there
but when you have something fresh and
then you freeze it and then you thaw it
out is it the same no it's not the same
you know freezing is a form of
processing that does cause significant
nutrient damage to food you can see this
when you have something fresh then you
put it in the freezer and then you
thought out it's not the same it has
reduced value there's still some value
there but it's reduced value so I
strongly emphasize seeking out the best
quality fresh food that is available to
you the more fresh food you eat the
better the best quality food for our
health for energy for brain power is
food that has a lifeforce energy value
to it
food can food has as physical nutrients
for us proteins essential fatty acids
carbohydrates vitamins and minerals
fiber there's there's a lot of physical
nutrients but the best quality food has
more than physical nutrients in it he
has a lifeforce energy value to it and
the fresher the food the higher that
lifeforce energy value so don't take for
granted the issue of fresh food okay
most people do and they don't think
anything of taking food out of their
freezer or taking some type of
right food item you know you know out of
there out of there there pantry or
you're you're taking something eating
something out of a can you know if
that's all that's available to you okay
but if you really want to move toward
realizing your full health potential at
any time in your life the more fresh
food you eat the better the next issue
fundamentally important food quality
issue has to do with whether the food is
factory farmed or conventionally grown
and then and thus it's going to be
contaminated with chemicals to some
extent or whether the food is organic or
even better than that biodynamic or
permaculture or wild it's very important
especially for brain power to avoid
foods that are chemically contaminated
with pesticides just like fluoride as a
neurotoxic pesticides are neurotoxic
they hurt the brain in fact most people
don't understand how the poisons that
are referred to as pesticides how do
they kill bugs they destroy the insects
nervous system and one of my favorite
books that I've read over the years on
nutrition was a book written by a very
nutritionally minded neurologist by the
name of dr. David Perlmutter who in 2004
came out with a book called the better
brain book and the better brain book he
had had a lot of good nutritional advice
in it but my favorite chapter of the
better brain book was chapter 8 titled
getting the toxins out and dr.
Perlmutter who's a very accomplished
neurologist with great appreciation for
the importance of nutrition he
identified that the most harmful brain
toxins that were that that were all
exposed to to some extent are pesticides
because they are neurotoxic so the
eating organic issue or eating food that
even if it's not certified organic
eating food that is not chemically
contaminated this is a fundamentally
important issue for your overall
long-term brain health and for your
overall health - because pesticides also
like fluoride they also inhibit enzymes
- they inhibit they can inhibit
digestive enzymes and make it more
difficult for you to digest or food and
ultimately you need to digest your food
to extract nutritional value from your
food so chicagoland is actually rich in
resources for organic food there's
there's many stores that carry organic
food I I especially like a little store
that's on Western Avenue and Ukrainian
Village neighborhood 1025 northwestern
Avenue called Amish and healthy foods
all of the produce in that store all of
the vegetables and fruits are always
organic and they have a lot of other
unique food items but Amish and healthy
foods 10:25 Northwestern Avenue which be
which is between Augusta and division is
my favorite store - to shop at what I
actually like better than shopping at
stores is shopping at farmer's markets
when farmers markets are available you
know in the winter now there's still
some indoor farmers markets going on
like the Green City Market is still
going on but the outdoor farmers markets
of course have a much greater selection
of fresh foods and the beginning in the
late spring and summer into the fall but
it's very important to to seek out
high-quality real food that is not
chemically contaminated with any type of
toxic chemicals
that can be neurotoxic and hurts your
brain so the best way to do to to
provide that is actually to grow your
own food to some extent if that's not
available to you or it's only available
to you in a very limited way then I
think it's actually always worth the
time to seek out the resources for the
best quality real food that is available
to you
that's reliably not contaminated with
toxic chemicals farmers markets markets
are great for that or if you if you have
neighbors or you have family that Dec
rose some food make the most of of
homegrown food that is grown without any
type of chemicals at all but it's it's
fundamentally important to eat food that
is not going to insidiously poison you
in some way because it contains
chemicals and the thing is with with
pesticides they're not only on the food
they're in the food so even if you buy
like conventional food and then you
think well I'll just peel it or I'll
wash it off really good and that'll
eliminate the the the pesticides
well that will reduce them but you can't
eliminate what's in the food pesticides
are not only on the food they're also in
the food okay another another food
fundamental food quality issue is the
raw vs. cooked food issue now there's a
lot of reasons why people cook their
food and I certainly support to the vast
majority of people I work with to cook
their food but cook your food gently
it's always best to cook your food on
lower temperatures and more slowly doing
this you can serve more of the flavor
more of the moisture in the food you can
serve most importantly you can serve
most more of the nutritional value the
food is
easier to digest and you don't create
toxins in the food the most common
cooking methods cooking temperatures
that people have been misled to use in
America actually you're creating toxins
and the food as you're cooking it the
most common temperature that people are
misled to use for oven cooking 350
degrees at 350 degrees you're creating
toxins that are carcinogenic dr. Joseph
itch mentioned carbohydrates like like
there's a refined and processed
carbohydrates can contain acrylamide
acrylamide czar severely heat damaged
starch molecules that are carcinogenic
when you know what you bake a potato in
the oven at 350 degrees you're creating
acrylamide it's always best cook your
food at lower temperatures and more
slowly you don't create toxins you can
serve more nutrients the food always
tastes butter my teaching is ideally
never cook your food above 225 degrees
225 degrees is Fahrenheit 100 degrees
about 100 a little bit above 100 degrees
Celsius or centigrade but 225 degrees is
above the boiling point of water
Fahrenheit which is 212 degrees you can
cook any food at the boiling point of
water you can sterilize any food at the
boiling point of water in the case of
225 degrees you're a little bit above
the boiling point of water but there can
be a very significant nutritional
difference between the biological value
of raw food nutrition and cooked food
nutrition any food that you're only
familiar with in a cook state if you've
never eaten that same food in a raw
state consider if if it's practical
considered eating that food in a raw
state now there's some foods that are
really not they don't lend themselves to
be eating food raw that's like grains
and legumes unless they're sprouted you
can eat sprouted grains and legumes raw
but just you know uncooked grains and
legumes they have no dye have no
nutritional value for the
because the human human digestive system
cannot digest them but vegetables the
vast majority of vegetables especially
all vegetables that grow above the
ground salad vegetables and the fruiting
vegetables like tomatoes and potatoes me
too tomatoes and bell peppers and
cucumbers leafy greens they all can be
in a raw state but there can be a
difference between raw food nutrition
and cooked food nutrition there's one
particular animal food that is available
to all of us I was I'm very enthusiastic
for this particular animal food it's
eggs eggs I believe are actually the the
best food for nutritional value and
lifeforce energy value that is commonly
available to us that's that's relatively
inexpensive that can really be a health
enhancing food especially when you
consume it in the way that it's almost
certainly going to have the greatest
biological value for you and I'd like to
actually demonstrate that right now I
demonstrated this on the last time I was
on the Dean show yeah that would really
appreciate that okay so I got I got a
couple raw eggs from organically raised
very healthy chickens and an egg
nutritionally an egg nutritionally is
about is about 60 62 percent fat
calories all of the fat is in the yolk
an egg yolk is especially valuable
nutrition for the brain the egg yolk has
really valuable protein and it's got the
full spectrum of lipids that are
essential for our biology it has
unsaturated fat monounsaturated fats
some saturated fat cholesterol
cholesterol is absolutely essential for
our health
your body naturally makes cholesterol
and in case any of you don't know I
mentioned testosterone before
testosterone the the hormone that has a
huge influence on a man's energy
vitality his strength your body makes
testosterone from cholesterol all of
this
this medical propaganda that is
demonized cholesterol that's that's
business that's not medical science its
business setting people up to be
receptive consumers for
cholesterol-lowering drugs your body
naturally makes cholesterol it's in your
bloodstream every moment of your life
because cholesterol is essential for
life so be careful who you trust and
what you buy into but an egg is is is
rich in lipids that I just mentioned an
egg also has a small carbohydrate value
just a little bit of carbs but an egg
has really good quality protein lots of
vitamins and minerals enzymes and in a
raw state let's think of what this
represents this is a raw egg from a
healthy chicken it represents potential
life okay you put this egg underneath
the chicken or an incubator it'll hatch
a chicken
if you cook an egg will you hit can you
still have such a chicken of course that
you know you cook an egg you still get
nutritional value you get calories to
burn but you cook an egg you kill the
life-force energy value in that egg okay
so anyway I demonstrated this for Eddie
on the Dean show the last time I was on
and I called this the warrior way of
doing raw egg nutrition so you don't
need a glass you don't need anything
okay you just need you need your teeth
and and so this is you can see there's a
really nice tip to this particular egg
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
crack this egg on my canine tooth I'm
gonna punch a hole in it okay got a nice
hole in there I I've taken some of the
white but I'm gonna suck out all the
rest of the white by putting it up to my
lips
don't be afraid of real food be afraid
of McDonald's be afraid of Burger King
be afraid of coca-cola
be afraid of fake food okay the the
corporate dominated commercial food
industry has tons of money to program
the population all you could also say
brainwash you could also say mind
control the population and they get
people to accept fake food as real food
and real food like this your total
that's too dangerous to eat you could
get you got sick you could get ecoli you
can get salmonella well the fact of the
matter is there are nourishing
traditions all over the world for
consuming raw egg nutrition I've been
doing nutrition and health counseling on
a professional level for going on well
I'm in my fourth decade of doing it I've
worked with people all over the world
from all areas of the world Asia the
Middle East South Pacific Australia as
well as all basically all countries in
North America and South America of cross
paths with with people from all over the
world and I'm always interested in
learning about any nourishing traditions
from other parts of the world and there
are nourishing traditions for consuming
raw egg nutrition all over the world
often its mothers giving their children
raw egg nutrition sometimes it's just
the raw egg yolk and sometimes it's miss
mixed with honey or sugar which is not
ideal but you know this does represent
potential life and the time in our lives
when our body is most sensitive to
nutrition is when we're growing and
developing like this guy and those guys
over there you know if there's any other
you know that young man over there
leaning against the wall nutrition of
course affects us throughout
entire lives but it affects us most of
all when our body is growing and
developing so in America there's also
there's also a an area of American
culture where raw egg nutrition has long
been appreciated from many cultures and
that's bodybuilding weightlifting
athletes engaged in intense training
culture you know it's like there's the
the classic scene from the first Rocky
movie everybody familiar with the Rocky
movies you know Sylvester Stallone you
know in the very first Rocky movie which
was probably the very best one
you know he's when he's beginning his
training in earnest you know he's gonna
fight the champ Apollo Creed and and
what does he do there's this scene where
he craps what was that six or eight eggs
and a glass and he sucks that down you
know where did he get that from well
Stallone was familiar with bodybuilding
culture and boxers and serious training
and so why do they do riots rather than
cooked eggs for the reasons I'm
explaining to you there's a lot of great
nutritional value here but it's even
more than that it's lifeforce energy
value why egg nutrition in my experience
is often the most valuable rejuvenating
food for people or the food that helps
to support the body when we're putting
ourselves under intense physical stress
doing serious training so anyway I've
got I've got the hole punched in the egg
I think you can all see that well let me
show the camera is think that's it so
let's just see it's not a hard-boiled
egg it's a real raw egg okay
and so I've got the hole there now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna peel the top
of the shell okay and I'm gonna create
myself a little egg cup okay and then
I've kept that beautiful oh this is a
beautiful in that beautiful yolk now
look then that look yummy
okay so I got that the beautiful yolk in
there it's actually the yolk the yolk of
the egg is actually that's where the the
life-force is the white is like the
protection for the yolk and now I'm
going to put that life force energy
value and those of those helping those
how
the non heat damaged lipids the
unsaturated fat the monounsaturated fat
saturated fat the cholesterol all of
those nutrients the vitamins the
minerals the enzymes I'm going to put
that into my body right now
that is nutrition for better energy and
brainpower so I think I'll stop there